[Music]
hello there it's been three long weeks
since the fortnight gods have graced us
with an update worth delving into but it
sure is here today we are now entering
week 10 of season eight this is usually
when all the story beats of the season
start to become clear so if you've sat
your butt down and locked in code
adamaru to help me pay my rent let's
break down the map changes and secret
story updates this week
so the biggest thing of all first right
in the centre of the island it only came
true all the theories about a pyramid
coming to fortnite it happened or at
least it's beginning to happen for the
best part of a month we've watched the
cube queen giggle away in her ball of
reality summoning a power like none
we've ever seen before
cube town sprouted up around her and
began to build and right now it's this
there seems to be many updates to come
in the last few weeks of the season and
for some reason they always break my
replay files our fight with the cube
queen is imminent see you all at the end
of season event maybe that means the
blue cube will finally wake up because
this week it's still sat there doing
absolutely nothing
[Music]
now for the updates that are easy to
miss think back 10 whole weeks to day
one of the season all the alien vessels
fell to the ground and one of the debris
sites uncovered this
a fourth bunker just like the three we
saw on day one of chapter two under the
shack to the north on the seabed to the
west and under a bush to the east and
now there's one just below pleasant park
i watched this every update and nothing
at all happened until today check it out
right now excavators have moved into the
area just like they did in chapter one
when they were looking for the vault
they are here to dig something up and
that so happens to coordinate with
something happening nearby a brand new
io base maybe the construction is going
well and maybe here within one week
this would be one of the first times
we've seen the construction of an io
base in-game usually an update drops we
all download it and suddenly a brand
spanking new perfectly erected building
is in place not this time we're going to
watch it build it's like hut watch io
edition what we can gather from this is
that this building will be important to
the story it's far too late in the
season for something irrelevant to be
added so i'm thinking this is a
defensive station to fire rockets at the
cube queen or take out the caretakers or
maybe we'll just use it as a place to
hug before the island is nuked from
history
okay we gotta get serious now because
something happened today that i've been
waiting for since day one of the new
chapter graham the gnome has gone
[Music]
for the last few years he sat proudly on
top of the radio station mast he's
watched everything with us and never
flinched but now he's gone this ties
into a much bigger story of the gnome
exodus they're aware something bad is
coming to the island and have been
trying to tell us to escape four weeks
now last update the final genomes caught
the bus in pleasant park and now every
single one of those little keemstar
warner bees have fled to the edge of the
island up to the north at craggy cliffs
a dozen gnomes including graham are
boarding the final boats to leave the
island to the west near the viking ship
another crew are ready to leave
including the dude that just lays down
all the time and then we have the crew
from the prison break a plan was hatched
to break the captured gnomes out of the
sheriff's office and flee south to the
lake above misty this worked flawlessly
until the group reached the dam three
weeks ago after falling down and
becoming stuck the crew was somehow able
to get moving again and this week can be
found in the swampland get your butt
over to this shack and you'll see the
biggest gang of gnomes ever recorded in
the wild
saying their final goodbyes and sailing
away
could they be making their own island or
just getting out of the blast radius
we'll find out soon oh and here's
something i didn't expect another sacred
gnome is goldie he's always lived in a
toilet down by the dam
yeah i don't write the law i just record
here he could always be found in a room
with four walls and no way out he liked
it in his toilet and that's where he
stayed all golden and shiny and now you
know what i'm gonna say he's gone from
this location he's moved with the group
all the way to the south and he's
leaving the helen too so now i put this
to you are there any gnomes left behind
i challenge you to find a gnome on the
island and take a screenshot be sure to
give a name to the gnomes you find
[Music]
here's a strange update which may not
mean anything at all but check this when
i logged in today look at the mini-map
here for some reason the viking ship is
no longer on the minimap is this just an
error or is this telling us something we
should know i have no idea at all but i
thought i'd report this to you all the
same the sole surviving alien dude from
last season who lived in a house all on
his own in literally his own bubble is
now walking around outside his house
he's been cooped up in there for 10
weeks he's been in isolation too long so
stretching his legs will do him good oh
and this will break your heart if you
stand here long enough and watch him
he'll knock on the neighbor's door
nearby and try to greet them but he's
all alone nobody else lives here and it
hurts my heart so much someone please go
visit this guy he's been alone for far
too long i'm gonna go ring my grandma i
feel so guilty right now
other small things of note are that the
sharks are back they were recently
removed completely but now there's quite
a lot of them again so have fun with
your fishing rod and if you're wondering
if there's any change at the tiny chair
no it's exactly the same as last time it
does look like this is the end for it
which is a shame and again down at the
bunker where we can find sloan there's
still no difference down there
everything has remained how it was last
time an important update i haven't
covered this season that i was certain
would be relevant is down in the
woodlands a yellow shipping container
appeared in week one and beneath it was
a secret base someone had been living in
trying to stay unnoticed i'll be honest
i thought something would have happened
by now but nope it's just a secret poi
for the season so to those who dm me
telling me to cover this consider it
covered it's a cool place let's all hide
down here during the event and regret
everything over to the patch notes and i
know i don't usually cover these as they
are usually hella boring but just read
the first line update 18.40 is here and
the island is destabilizing this is to
announce the arrival of the salvaged
brute and it's a genius call back to the
first time we saw them appear during the
season x reveal
season x is here and the world is
destabilizing fast but don't worry and
now it's my duty to implore you to spend
every last piece of gold you have to
bring the brute to the game don't do it
for me don't do it for penny do it to
upset twitch streamers the brute strikes
fear into their hearts and they reveal
their true selves i'm not playing
anymore bro i'm off this game
i rest my case
the shopping cart is returning this week
too i haven't found it in game yet but
if it brings back the nostalgia of
chapter one count me in so if the
leakers are right this is the very last
update of the season so with that in
mind i took a look around to see if we
could see what happened over the years
did you know that the blast stain from
the spaceship thruster back in season
three is still here on the mountain side
that mini mission had us sending that
pod back into space
and over at sweaty sands there is still
the remains of last season's believer
beach in the waters around the beach are
tons of old items that once filled this
place now they're left to rot in the
waters below hey yo including this guy
so if this is the end of chapter 2 i'll
be sure to make a video going over the
entire story sometime but that leads to
a question which chapter would you say
is the best chapter 1 or chapter two
i'll keep my eye out for arguments in
the comments below i'm adam you're
awesome and so are these guys who have
kindly used my code and marrow this week
really appreciate it thank you very much
okay i think we're done and dusted here
i'll see you next time
oh there is one other thing this guy and
his crew arrived yay